can we talk about the donkey please yeah
Jenny yeah go on tell me about her Jenny
was lovely she told me about her the
first time she's gorgeous she's gorgeous
she's gorgeous but she was also a bit of
a nervous wreck which is understandable
because film sets if you don't know what
you're doing can be a very awkward place
to be so she was very when she arrived
she was she actually had a support she
had a support donkey
she had a support donkey
and I'm so ashamed I don't remember to
support donkey's name
I do I do Rosie Rosie was Jenny's
support junkie right so Jenny was the
star Rosie was her support donkey they
called Rosie Jenny's quote unquote
standing and she did sometimes but
literally Jenny would be always looking
to see where Rosie was and Rosie had a
little kind of a a peaceful effect on
her Constitution you could see it